work out to this video playing on do
Ross from Austria stony 235 ok a French
defence a classical variation and this
is usually called the Steinitz let's see
that many lines here there should be
seven taking in also a 686 s maybe
mainline nowadays but there should be
seven had gained some popularity ok this
is one of the topical ideas the deform p
sacrifice ok why is this even working at
all I it this should be for probably mhm
ok I'm just ignore it I thought I don't
know why this is working I know that
this is the idea but ok let's just play
this position it cannot be too terrible
hook like okay I understand these ideas
to go before even interesting yeah very
interesting line check came I'll go
again with the keep it simple approach
that will not equalize but let me play a
game this is the way to go really maybe
an idea for to deform ito to deform
maybe I have before though this an idea
maybe for some counter play yeah but I'm
weekend I am weakened on the go inside
yeah but still it's hard to imagine how
to get anything going without the move
oopsies not taking yeah okay in fact
that that's also quite logical if I go a
five yeah but taking just leaves me
worse I mean this also leads me worse
but just a question of what what's the
lesser evil here yeah okay so he really
gotten lately opening okay I'm 34 I need
to get rid of the weakness and you can
just play rugae one okay wow that's
maybe even better interesting but if I
go Bishop a six let's just consider this
for mode it's still good for what
you
Wow okay obviously I cannot take on b3
is threatening to take on a four though
exposing the whole Queen side Wow
wow I'm really busted here that's that's
very strong move rugby one I don't every
I don't see us even remotely a defense
Bishop a three takes on a forum for ya
ok I don't see a move you just be a four
let's just money now I thought night c4
takes pawn takes I need to prevent
Bishop d7 okay well maybe not maybe not
maybe I can on Bishop e7 go to f8 and
then let's say g5 lat it's also not
playable
maybe you can even take on a six maybe
yeah came upon 97 is also not not moved
on okay takes with the bishop check on
be 7q eight we cannot even play g6 king
king great great Rock be a test knight
c6 ok ty morning okay we try for come to
play with g5
okay why does of course winning here
with best play but it still needs to do
it check I don't know maybe what he did
is good but I'm not I'm not totally
convinced go here let's check again ok
I'll still try it check
p4 p5 oh my black resigns yeah that was
just a very bad position out of the
opening remarkable really remarkable
yeah well I do know that this is this is
a theoretically hotline at the moment
and black young i don't know i mean i
think d4 it's not like bad but it's
considered to be very tricky 94 94 94
seems to be the point as this stuff
computer he actually gives it as good
for wide yeah and here i mean to know
check check I was trying to skip and Su
keep it simple approach and maybe this
was really bad I mean as possible I am
can I mostly thought about taking but
this is just much better he really
played a great game here I mean III
didn't play it well but he took a good
to go to draw in touch off my mistakes
yeah why it's just better yeah I wonder
what can you do this was all very very
nicely played no I took maybe maybe here
I can defend better I mean not maybe I a
soda candy felt better because what I
did just loses and while black is worse
here that's clear I
not sure that I should lose so easily
maybe maybe night here I don't know I
mean and this is what about what I
played is losing group b 1 is just very
strong I mean other rules are also good
but I thought at least I'm struggling
the main problem is that those pieces on
the B file if he takes for example this
oops sorry this is also just excellent
for white and winning ok here I don't
have a moose I simply am simply lost
here he threatens be a foreign winds and
don't have a move I mean this is
exceptionally ugly I mean if eyes with
some miracle could get the bishop to d5
maybe it's a just alarm somewhat
interesting but this way I'm just I'm
just toast check absolutely no chance to
defend it gap very nicely played by my
opponent yeah actually I would have need
to to look look it up this opening here
there they are so near that there must
be some better way to play me this is
not considered to be a fantastic for for
why this Bishop d3 idea but i don't i
don't really know the the theoretical
details alright thanks for watching